hello everyone and welcome to some more
updated news from the candidates
tournament 2024 yesterday in my previous
video I announced that we still have six
players in the race for the spots of the
F candidates tournament well now the six
has dropped down to four Paran makulu
and laner Dominguez Perez are out of the
race for the FED candidates tournament
uh maulu simply because he already lost
too much rating he first had catch up to
ler and then overtake Wesley and he's
currently down Five Points so that will
not be a possibility for him and lener
well I will tell you what he said um but
this game perfectly illustrates why one
would come to such a decision and we're
going to discuss the uh qualification
process for the candidates tournament a
little bit after the game but it's a
really brutal game you have to calculate
a lot and here he faces pranav Anand who
we've featured on the channel quite a
few times I believe and um as you can
see laner is some 200 almost 250 points
higher rated so when you play someone
who is 250 points lower rated than you
you should be able ble to win with the
white pieces but that's uh one of the
problems when when 27 plus 100 players
are constantly facing each other as in
each other in close tournaments uh you
just um can't afford to play every game
for a win okay sometimes Magnus does
that but that's other than him I mean
it's not really a possibility and they
have uh systems that where where you're
incredibly solid with black you just
want to equalize uh you probably heard
like Anish giri said um million times in
interviews that you know uh this
equalizes this is this is a draw first I
want to find the draw and then I
continue the game uh but when you're
playing open tournaments you're playing
against the players who are hungry they
will come at you with everything they
have they will play Crazy lines and you
you will have to fight um you will have
to fight every game even if uh even if
Magnus decided to play an open
tournament uh it's uh very unlikely that
he can just you know uh Brute Force his
way to the first place at the end of
like 9 or 11 rounds uh but okay we're
going to discuss that a little bit more
after we check out the game Let's uh
check out what happened here so lener
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to E5 by panav
and it's going to be a fairly
theoretical opening that we've seen
quite a few times Ru Lopez Pawn to
Bishop to B5 is on the board A6 morphe's
defense pawn bishop to A4 and Knight to
F6 we have castles and Bishop to E7 D3
and B5 so pretty much every game we see
this bishop B3 pwn to D6 C3 and castles
King side we have Pawn to H3 and Bishop
to B7 preparing to move the Knight and
then strike with C5 Knight B to D2 and
now Knight to A5 we have uh Bishop back
to C2 of course you do not want to allow
this trait to happen H and now Pawn to
C5 grabbing the center uh and Rook to E1
you need additional support for this E4
Pawn if you are to develop your pieces
you know you want to bring that Knight
over to G3 or or or E3 Rook to E8
preparing to tug the bishop in with
Bishop to f8 and now Knight to F1 we
have Pawn to H6 Knight to G3 and now
Bishop to f8 so again we've seen this
like a thousand times uh Pawn to D4 we
see a central breakthrough here captures
uh captures captures and now e captures
and Knight captures on D4 and sometimes
people go Rook to C8 here G6 is a known
move Pawn to D5 is a known move praf
chooses Queen to C7 again which has been
played many times and uh usually as it
is the strongest move for White Queen C7
is met with Bishop to F4 but Lan here
wants to uh figure out a different way
to approach this position he plays
Bishop to D2 and it is now as of move 18
that we have a completely new game so he
put some pressure on the Knight but
really the bishop is coming to C3 to
assume this long diagonal but by playing
Bishop to D2 instead of Bishop to F4 you
allow Knight to C4 sort of to come with
Tempo uh pressuring the bishop and
attacking the undefended B2 Pawn so
Bishop to C3 and now Pawn to B4
sacrificing the pawn to capture the B2
Pawn so really trading pawns Bishop
captures we have Knight captures
attacking the queen and queen to F3 and
now just Knight back to C4 uh and now
Rook a to C1 nicely aligning The Rook
with the black queen and now Pawn to A5
attacking the bishop and here H you have
to decide uh what to what to do with
your dark Square Bishop lir played
Bishop to B3 he decided to trade dark
Square Bishop for for the Knight on C4
uh but Bishop to C3 seems to be the way
to go here it's a a crazy move uh but uh
uh for for example if something like
Knight the E5 attacking the queen and
putting pressure on the bishop so the
queen still has to defend the bishop
let's say play uh Queen to E3 and now D5
trying to blast open the E file as the
rook and queen occupied uh Bishop to A4
is the move you attack the rook and now
once Knight C4 attacks the queen you
will move the queen and now look at this
if if the Rook moves for example Rook e
to C8 now you'll play Knight D to F5 and
this is now objectively winning for
white so not all of the moves are forced
I just want to show what is possible if
let's say Bishop to C3 was played with
maybe an a suboptimal move from black so
now let's say Knight captures on e4
Knight captures on H6 with check that's
why the bishop is so powerful in this
diagonal G captures Knight captures on
e4 and now if you capture back or if you
don't then white is just better Queen to
G4 check where does the black king go to
King to H7 now Queen F5 check King to G8
and queen F6 there is no defense against
Checkmate you will have to give up your
queen and that's pretty much it uh so
Bishop to to C3 qu quite a bit better
than Bishop to B3 Bishop to B3 was what
lineer played now a captures on B4
Bishop captures on C4 now threatening
some nasty discoveries but just Rook 8
to C8 saying you don't have any good
nasty discoveries and if you just play
Bishop back to B3 of course panov will
give up the queen for two Rooks so here
uh after Rook eight to C8 Queen back to
B3 now lir has some different plans he
wants to play Bishop to E6 uh and pav
goes for it Knight captures on e4 Knight
captures we have Bishop captures on e4
and now Bishop to E6 putting pressure on
the rook and forcing panov to take the
The Rook here so he gives up the queen
for two Rooks Queen captures and now
First bishop captures an F7 that was the
difference between the this and previous
position a slight swiish and uh King to
H7 and now Rook captures on C1 Rook
captures on C1 with check King to H2 and
now how do you deal with this position
it's a really really wild position where
uh one uh slight inaccuracy could cause
PR of the game and let's say you just
want to save your Rook here you play
something like Rook e to C8 makes sense
you double up on the C file already F3
is a huge problem what do you do with
the bishop uh it's uh once you trade off
that Bishop then white is just better
because this bishop is the one uh that
is protecting the black king from all
the checks that the White Queen can do
and if you go Bishop to B1 which is your
only other Square now Bishop to E6 six
attacks The Rook basically takes away
the C8 Square from the rook and once you
move that Rook now you play Queen
captures on B4 then you go to B8 the C8
square is covered and then of course the
bishop will have to move then you go
Queen G7 check and so on this is now
winning for white but per Now does not
fall for it he plays Pawn to D5 and what
is what is the meaning of this uh well
the meaning of this is that now if you
capture The Rook there's this nasty
Bishop to D6 check and once you block it
there's Rook to H1 Checkmate so here has
to figure out how to go about this he
plays Queen to G3 which is the the best
idea and now Rook to C3 first attacks
the White Queen and now Pawn to F3
chases away the bishop but Prav doesn't
move the bishop he plays Rook to d8 he
wants to win the White Queen by securing
um securing it with Bishop to D6 and now
uh still uh Queen to G4 objectively best
and after Bishop D6 check G3 as the
Knight covers the C2 square but it looks
very odd opening up your king like this
so lir played Knight to B5 attacking the
rook and now look at this bishop to
F5 uh saving the bishop not caring about
The Rook if you capture The Rook then of
course the pass Pawn is just a monster
here even if you try to stop it it's
defended by the bishop and now the dwn
starts marching forward so instead after
Bishop to F5 Queen to E1 was played but
now uh pranav is completely winning but
it's not easy to see why feel free to
pause the video and try to you know soak
in the position a little bit uh because
there's quite a lot to consider here
find the winning idea for for pranav
while I give you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
this wild sequence of moves and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh it is Pawn to D4 that's the move
you have to play and okay it looks uh
you know natural just start advancing
your pass Pawn but you know there's
quite a bit more to it and uh since I'm
not showing clocks here as it's a
classical game it wasn't really an issue
of time trouble they had like okay
elenir had a minute and 44 seconds but
pav had over 5 minutes on the clock and
he did not play it but D4 is incredible
uh because there's no move for white uh
let's say you play Bishop to B3 of
course you want to get your Bishop to
safety maybe uh help out with the
control over over these squares now the
idea is Rook C5 you attack the Knight
and how do you how do you deal with this
there's just no good way to to play this
the Knight is just tra if you play Queen
captures on B4 which is kind of your
only move then comes Rook to B8 uh
threatening to capture the Knight and
you can't even defended with A4 because
just Rook captures opens up a discovery
on the queen and you lose so you cannot
play A4 you have to play Queen captures
on D4 but now just Rook C captures on B5
and now you have two Rooks and the dark
Square Bishop for a queen of course that
is way too much material uh so after
Queen to E1 this would have been winning
but P went back uh he gave he gave lir
uh uh
a moment of you know uh to catch his
breath and he didn't go for Knight to D4
and you have to play this it kind of
controls the entire board stops the D
Pawn attacks the bishop controls B3 uh
and also puts more pressure on E6 but he
went for Bishop to E6 right away and now
Bishop captures Queen captures and again
there is a clean way for p of
to maybe not win maybe there's like a
you know 0.1 chance that an engine holds
this but but you know a human playing
yeah you can win this uh and peraf found
it only he found it a move to late here
uh he played King to h8 he wanted to
avoid all of the all of the checks as
the king the light Square diagonal has
now opened up but the way to win this is
Bishop to C5 and the reason why Bishop
to C5 is the winning move because okay
everyone can just start pushing of
course you you guys are wondering about
D4 the Knight simply captures it and
then if Rook captures you lose the Rook
on C8 so you have to prepare the push by
playing Bishop to C5 and I'll look at
the race Pawn to F4 Pawn to D4 Pawn to
F5 Pawn to D3 Pawn to F6 now you bring
the bishop back and your Pawn is safe
here the Knight cannot contest the pawn
and now after F captures on G7 and
Bishop captures yes you do have to
suffer through a few checks but uh you
know it's nothing serious Knight to D6
okay uh you are threatening some checks
and also threatening to win the pawn uh
but just Rook to C7 and you cannot touch
the pawn uh of course uh you you just
blunder uh the piece Bishop 5 check will
pick up the Knight so what do you play
Queen to D5 but now Rook to D7
threatening the Knight and now Knight F7
check okay possible if Rook captures he
will capture The Rook here but now King
G8 and now some discoveries Knight to D6
check King comes to H7 Queen captures on
D3 with Check Yes you also have to allow
that King to h8 and now again Knight to
F7 check King to G8 and now uh there's
really no other way to continue uh your
knight is hanging there's no way to save
it you will have to play Knight C dos on
H7 and after some checks here Bishop to
G7 okay uh this is the position you have
two Rooks and the bishop for the queen
uh like I said maybe some super precise
engine can hold this but a human very
unlikely uh so that was the way to go
but pav played King to h8 First seems
like it's the same idea he will play
Bishop to C5 next but uh it's now lineer
who starts advancing first he plays Pawn
to F4 Bishop to C5 Now Pawn to F5 you
can see how it's much different the D4
Pawn to F6 D3 and now F captures on G7
while the pawn is still on D3 King
captures now Queen to E5 check King to
G8 and now Queen to E6 with check King
G7 Queen to E5 with check and after King
to G8 it was I think in this position
that they agreed to a draw uh because uh
well it's a draw it's a draw by
three-fold repetition and if you try to
hide your king let's say queen F6 check
you want to escape just Queen to E6
check there's no way to escape Bishop D7
can even be played but now just um uh
queen to queen to G8 with check and if
you run over here then Queen to D5 with
check the Knight control C7 if you go
back then another check if you block
with the bishop then this check Bishop
D7 and just check check check check
check uh so yeah you you've seen how
complicated the game it was and uh what
it takes for for a 2745 player to to
take down a 2500 player panav Anand who
who is uh obviously playing much better
than his rating as our the Indian
youngsters uh but um yeah it's not it's
not easy and uh it if anything it was
only only pav who could have won this
game had he found that um first the the
pawn push and then the bishop to C5 idea
uh but yeah Prav takes the draw and uh
lineer decides that he is out of the
race of the FED candid tournament I'm
pretty sure that it's possible still for
him to to qualify but as he announced
that he's out even if he like wins all
the other games until the the end of the
tournament I guess he's out as uh
through his own words he says that
although I had all the desire in the
world to fight for the spot in the
candidates and that is why I came in the
first place uh I did feel from the start
that I need to keep being objective all
the time and I think I came to the point
where I am simply risking too much and
we've seen a couple of U moves where
lineer stepped out of the territory that
you that you would usually uh go to
against a maybe 2700 player specifically
with the bishop to D2 line and some of
the other Maybe suboptimal moves uh but
you just can't play like that and it it
also shows you what it takes to win an
open tournament doesn't matter who you
are doesn't matter if you're Magnus
you're just not going to brute force
your way uh through an open tournament
you're going to face uh you know
incredible young players who will come
at you with all sorts of lines you've
never seen before because you're just uh
I mean you're you're just too old you
can't follow follow Theory as as much as
young players can I mean young players
will just you know study Theory 12 hours
a day there there's no way you can
compete with that so if you survive that
okay you will survive it for maybe one
round two rounds three rounds uh but
will you survive it for n nine rounds
it's a bit of a different story and it
also uh you know brings into question
this whole idea of qualifying uh to the
candidates tournament via rating uh as
okay that's been the topic of discussion
for like the past two decades is is it
okay should they just abolish it because
you have these uh uh you know top 10
players who are only playing close
tournaments uh you know they play a
close tournament they have like seven
draws and one win and they keep their
rating or seven loss and seven draws and
one loss uh again they will keep their
rating and it's very hard to overtake uh
some of them via rating uh whereas you
know maybe maybe that spot should be
awarded to someone who who played like
incredible uh chess through maybe five
open tournaments throughout the year and
played Fighting Chance someone who plays
to win maybe to to Dazzle everyone not
just not to lose so those are questions
um for someone else you know I'm just U
enjoying enjoying chess here but yeah
there are some you know valid questions
that should be answered or maybe should
we should we should we increase the
candidates turn maybe to 12 players
should we use a completely different
system on deciding the who who who faces
the champion you know maybe it would be
best if we you know went back how they
did it in the old days where you know
capablanca said I want to challenge uh I
want to challenge Alaska for the title
and then Alaska could decide whether he
accepts the challenge or not uh uh and
then okay in the end he just gave up the
challenge without capablanca actually
winning the match uh if you guys
remember Alaska first gave up the title
he made capablanca champion and then
lasar challenged capablanca as the
Challenger and then he lost they didn't
even finish the match after a couple of
games lar just said okay there's just no
playing this guy uh so yeah that's the
game and a little bit of info about the
candidates tournament so now four remain
in the race it is Wesley and Anish who
have the best chances but depending on
uh what happens uh in the chai Grand
Masters also GES and arjuni might have
something to say about that uh so or if
you know some other super tournament
emerges where someone else will grab
like 50 points maybe hunts plays two
tournaments and you know he wins like 50
rating points you you never know uh but
yeah that's the game unless something
changes uh those are the the top four
for now I would like to thank an
anonymous person Benjamin hyberger Alan
aelf Gregory Novak and Kenneth f for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon continuing to
check up on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and the rest of your
week